and i remember
someone saying rick turns himself into a
pickle i do just remember
kind of immediately leaping on it and
saying well
because that sounds like such a dumb
innocuous thing like why would rick do
that and the answer has to be the most
complex
thing
i'm not a big fan of
idea worship i i think that people make
the mistake of um trying to come up with
a good idea i i think that television
in particular is
for better for worse it's a
it's a comfort
tool jeff
winger was was the parts of me that had
adapted to
performance and manipulation of others
and uh um getting people to like them
and materialism and all those things and
that avid was
not not the real me but the parts of me
that would be left over if you carved
all that jeff winger off this is a great
time for
point of view is really selling you know
i think we've discovered something that
that old world television
either had mistaken or was lying to us
about which was the idea that there was
this goal you're supposed to accomplish
this goal of having everybody in the
living room watch one show these cool
episodes where you take an icon
and you say
well what makes them tick on the inside
and you do that by depriving them of of
everything
and then you so you learn so much more
about them everybody's got the long
version of their story but it's sort of
like the headlines are sort of similar
to aisha's i guess just watching tv and
then going i want to affect people with
through this thing and moving out here
and stumbling into a job
[Music]
the
so-called story circle is my attempt to
remove
all of the hard and repeated work from
the task of breaking a story we do an
eight-step story process here i call it
an embryo you've got a character that
you can identify with that has some kind
of need wish incompletion causes them to
go across a threshold where the story
changes direction they go down a road of
trials searching for something they find
it whether they like it or not it kind
of kicks their ass and they come back to
the world they started in having changed
you need to go search for something find
it take it and then return changed i'm
pickle rick
i remember
being in the writer's room and i
remember
someone's saying rick turns himself into
a pickle i do just remember
kind of immediately leaping on it and
saying well
because that sounds like such a dumb
innocuous thing like why would rick do
that and the answer has to be the most
complex uh
thing the concept for the episode really
is the entire first act as opposed to an
idea like morty makes a robot
the idea of pickle brick really was
everything that you see in the at least
the first 10 minutes of a pickle rick
episode the way i was thinking about it
was it was like the rv breaks down in
the desert episode of breaking bad these
cool episodes where you take an icon
and you say
well what makes them tick on the inside
and you do that by depriving them of of
everything
and then you so you learn so much more
about them pickle rick is sort of it's
very emblematic of of what i love the
most about rick and morty because my
partnership with justin gives me this
really
fun license to go yeah like let's take
this really dumb thing incredibly
seriously it's like a really freeing
thing he just retains his uh
innocence about stuff like he just likes
what he likes and he just has these
thoughts that are crazy and childish and
treating that as if it's as important as
a nuclear power plant it's like
my favorite activity
i don't commit to
a schedule i don't have a work ethic i'm
a really really lazy person i always
tell people to just follow your laziness
because
laziness isn't people
not wanting to do something laziness is
people who are faced with having to do
something they don't want to do
everybody gets out of bed even on a
saturday you eventually want to do
something so the best thing you can do
for yourself especially in a
capitalist democracy is
find the thing that you really like to
do and try to figure out how to turn
that into your job i know that that's a
terrible advice in this economy everyone
has to go do stuff they don't want to do
but but i mean truly that is the only
way that i manage to stay productive is
by finding ways to get paid to do the
things that i would rather do
otherwise i'll just sit around and play
video games uh i think that you i'm not
a big fan of
idea worship i i i think that people
make the mistake of um trying to come up
with a good idea i i i think that
television
in particular is for better or for worse
it's a it's a comfort uh tool it's a
it's a it's a family that that you're
seeking whether it's a workplace family
or a it's it's um and the best tv is
it's it's
the idea is
it's just a it's just a generic
foundation and it's the execution it's
the it's the actors that you discover
it's the stories that you tell that that
make a show good or bad so i
and and and so because it starts with a
script
i
i always look for what i think uh
non-writing executives look for which is
a writer who is passionate about
something
um of all the characters you've created
which one do you most identify with
uh
i i mean like i guess for me it was
always like a
straight down the middle split on
community between jeff winger and abed
that
that was the idea was that
jeff
winger was was the parts of me that had
adapted to
performance and manipulation of others
and uh getting people to like them and
materialism and all those things and
that abid was
not not the real me but the the
the
parts of me that would be left over if
you carved all that jeff winger off and
vice versa that neither is the real me
that that's the that there's there's a
if you fused those two characters
together in a perfect 50 50 uh alloy
that it would it would turn into this
like slovenly
weird stammering um
uh
selfish uh
person
this is a great time for
e point of view is really selling you
know i think we've discovered something
that that old world television either
had mistaken or was lying to us about
which was the idea that there was this
goal you're supposed to accomplish this
goal of having everybody in the living
room watch one show so knight rider's
got a sexy guy for the mom and the sexy
woman for the dad and then it's a
talking car for the kids and all that
stuff and and this golden age of
television is being driven by frankly
the fragmentation of the media down to
the point where there's not enough money
to support the kind of guy that's chomps
on a cigar and makes that his goal and
and all of a sudden you've got vince
gilligan saying like i'm going to tell
you a really specific story from the
darkest part of my soul
and you have shonda rhimes is popping up
and you have you you
at fx like john landgraf has this
culture over there about point of view
everything is about point of view and
and we've discovered that it doesn't
have to be relatable you don't have to
be
transgender to recognize to be intrigued
and drawn into transparent and you don't
have to be
black to watch atlanta you can even
acknowledge that you don't understand
thirty percent of it if you're white and
you gotta get and that you like it that
way um because people people people
people really like point of view they
like they like specific stuff um and so
and so uh that is i think it's like
marketability be damned you know
somebody comes into
if it's about collaboration if it's
about production and you're looking for
a writer with a pitch then listen for
actually like the kind of opposite of
what your instincts might say like like
listen for something that sounds so
unsellable and then because
it's a derivative medium that's all
about watering things down and
compromising them and executing them so
it's like find something
insane and draw a frame around that and
sell that you know that's what rick and
morty is it's just it's just like this
thing that should not be allowed to be
a show and then i came in with my kind
of sterile
you know tv muscles and and said okay
but it's a family and
all that stuff does rick's
knowledge and awareness of the universe
make his life harder to lead and enjoy
yeah and doesn't that take you back to
the timeless question of what's the
point of learning more if i just have to
get through my week yeah it's rough and
i think that that's maybe the one area
of overlap between community and rick
and morty which
really have completely different almost
opposite religions
communities religion communities
religion is that anything that is human
is more valuable than anything inhuman
any system any rule if it does not have
a beating heart it is wrong
compared to anything with a beating
heart and what is rick and morty's
religion rick and morty's religion is
nobody exists on purpose if you are
terrified by that the best we can say is
you're not alone i i it uh
it's mainly like
pierce is the baby boomer like i said so
that comes with all kinds of foot and
mouth sort of attempts to not be racist
resulting in being racist then you have
britta who's the sort of the defiant uh
early 30s late 20s white girl who also
wants to save the world wants to be
responsible for it is fighting against
her own selfishness so she's very often
inadvertently uh
uh the voice of of the oppressor on
accident you have the the younger
characters troy annie and abed they're
they exist in this sort of like what is
being called by academics as this
post-racial world which some would scoff
at like like we could never have that
but but like they're they're bored with
race you know like this is how i
perceive people in their early 20s like
it's hack now uh to them they they're
over it uh and and and so they exist in
that world but britain jeff just sort of
like he'll say anything to to to get
what he needs and he's aware that
politics and race and gender are all hot
buttons that you can push to get anybody
to think anything you want and that's
how he gets by um so that i don't that's
that's how i think about the world i'm
obsessed with race i'm obsessed with
gender i'm obsessed with the things that
divide us i i can't stop thinking about
them if i try i'll i'll make an ass with
myself even more so than i that i do
when i'm not trying so so i i embrace it
and then that's what the show's about
it's called community because it's about
like
it examines dynamics between people
while i was there i took a biology class
and because i was 32 and had nothing
else to do i was like acing biology and
all these like younger people who are
like juggling full-time jobs at jiffy
lube and like like also having to take
biology and still full of hormones and
all this stuff they're getting c's and
they're seeing my a's and they come up
to me and they go we want to study with
you
and they say it in such a way that makes
me feel like i'm going to be a huge jag
if i say no
and i i didn't want to though because i
had nothing to gain but to you know i
was like what do you want to siphon off
my a
uh gonna just suck my genius juice out
of the fuel tank and what do i get a
keychain
and that's the kind of person i was at
that time i still am but but uh
since then i've joined a nunnery uh no i
i i was uh and that's why i was in this
tiny room in the glendale uh community
college library with these guys learning
cellular mitosis for an exam and i
didn't get it and they didn't get it and
i was miserable to be showing up for
this and it was 9 p.m and then at some
point during that evening
an experience happened to me that i
bookmarked in my head for the future
when i ran out of ideas about robots and
stuff and i i the experience was
oh my god i like these people who have
nothing to do with my career
i like these people who have never who i
would never hang out with if i met him
in a bar i like these people who i i i'm
bonding with them for some reason other
than
uh
you know
i don't know like like thinking that
it's gonna contribute to me somehow
uh i was born white and uh
this wizard appeared on my porch one day
and said you get to write in tv uh
because of this and for no other reason
and they i was whisked away to a magical
world many of you don't know about uh
where opportunities grow on trees and we
roll around in them naked and just [ __ ]
on them
uh
and it's so fun and i'm so untalented
now i i i might my story's very similar
to aisha's actually i just grew up like
watching tv obsessively at the
uh lower middle class suburbs of
milwaukee i i i i ended up doing improv
and stand up and then was writing a
comic book uh with my friend rob schrab
who that got optioned so we moved out to
la thinking that meant we got to write
the movie uh
that's not what that means uh so we we
bought our sid field books and things
and we learned to write a spec
screenplay of our own we got very very
lucky uh got repped by uta got a meeting
with robert zemeckis new company that he
was just forming uh pitched them like 10
ideas and sold one of them which was
monster house which took 10 years to
make in the meantime we [ __ ] around a
lot and uh i i went through a lot of ups
and downs and things and i actually
never worked on any staffs of anybody
else's shows um
i just kept writing pilots that didn't
nobody wanted to shoot and uh eventually
one stuck and that was uh the community
said so i went from
total schlub to uh showrunner which
sometimes is a little difficult because
i find myself working over people who
are really more than qualified like to
be in my position so uh it's it's it's i
have my own issues and uh
uh
and so that's it i don't know that's
everyone's got the long version of their
story but it's sort of like the
headlines are sort of similar to aisha's
i guess just watching tv and then going
i want to affect people with through
this thing and moving out here and
stumbling into a job
you